and we begin with some very very good
news it's been a long week for a lot of
people but this is fantastic
why 13 year old Jaime Claus who
disappeared the day her parents were
murdered in October has been found and
she is alive and she is safe
Jaime apparently escaped from captivity
yesterday in Gordon Wisconsin that's
about 65 miles north of her home in
Barron where she was last seen nearly
three months ago Jaime's rescue deepens
the mystery over what happened to her
and her parents local sheriff's will
only say that a suspect is in custody
her relatives say they never gave up
hope for her return Adriana Diaz is in
Gorder to show us how she was found
Adriana I know you were following this
story from the jump what amazing news
it is incredible news beyond 1/2 a mile
down this road is where the search for
Jaime cloth finally came to an end
this is where neighbors saw the face
everyone had been looking for this is
Jaime Clawson call 9-1-1 those were the
first words Peter Kozinski's heard when
he opened his front door Thursday in a
phone call he told us his neighbor had
been pounding on it standing with a
disheveled girl literally like I was
seeing a ghost because we've seen the
billboards and the commercials and all
that stuff and there she is in my
kitchen
you know Kaczynski says his neighbor was
walking her dog around 4:00 p.m. in this
remote and wooded area when class
appeared she immediately brought her two
Kaczynski's his home to call 9-1-1 he
said Kloss appeared thin and ragged
wearing what looked like leggings a
sweatshirt and oversized men's tennis
shoes he said she was quiet while they
waited for police to arrive roughly 15
minutes later she looked like the same
as in all the photos a little thinner
her hair was still the same color and
length she just looked a little on kept
like she hadn't been able to you know
take care of herself for some time
according to the Douglas County
Sheriff's Office 11 minutes after police
arrived a suspect was taken into custody
elsewhere flosses aunt su Allard was
overcome that the teen was found alive
it had been three months since her
parents were murdered and she vanished
without a trace james and denise cloths
were found shot to death and their
barren home on october 15th police
received a mostly inaudible 911 denise
classes cell phone around 1:00 a.m. when
authorities arrived just four minutes
later the front door was kicked in the
parents were dead and Jamie was gone for
months police and volunteers combed the
area for clues but the tight-knit
community kept the faith over the
holidays they held a Christmas tree
vigil for Claus her family never gave up
hope
despite few promising leads Jamie we
need you here with us to fill that hole
we have in our hearts we all love you to
the moon and back and we will never stop
looking for you
Kaczynski's believes Jamie had been held
in a home about half a mile from his he
described the people that live there as
different and said they kept a low
profile
police took Jamie to a hospital in
Duluth Minnesota and she is expected to
be reunited with her family later today
gail o Adrianna thank you so much I
can't wait I can't wait for the reunion
there are so many questions in this
story and you know it reminds me so much
of the Elizabeth Smart case who went
through unspeakable horrors and in the
end she's okay today she was missing for
nine months but to think about this
little girl who knew the whole time
she's being held captive since October
that her parents were dead and what
she'd be coming back to and what she'd
witness and what she do exactly what she
wouldn't but you're right I mean never
underestimate the resilience a young
person and it's so great that she has
her family around her as her on that we
have her we found we love her to the
moon and back all those people who kept
hope alive you know all those people
walking through the fields doing all the
hard work of trying to find her and now
that Hope has paid off a lot of people
just would have a good ending and she
went through the holidays but she is
okay I can't get enough of the story
want to hear more of course